Welcome back to Gary's Economics
todaywe're gonna explain "who pays tax?"
so I want to do a quick explanation basically of
exactly how the tax system works and who pays tax
um largely because there are a lot of sound bites
bouncing around that are intentionally misleading
which are designed to make people think that
the tax system is already unfairto the rich
so the big one which you hear, whichI get
thrown at me sometimes when I do interviews
is that the richest 1% already pay 28% of tax
now this is very misleading so the firstthing
is that is actually not the 'Richest' 1%of
people it is the top 1% of'Taxpayers'
now every year we get The Times Rich List
the rich people in the country and we
also get another list of the top taxpayers in the
country and I think it's really interesting to go
and compare these 2 lists, often what you'llfind
is there's almost nobody who is on both ofthe lists
which I think is quite interesting andthat is
because the people who pay the most tax
uh whilst they are generally rich people they are
NOT the richest people in the country and we're
going to explain in this video why 'people pay the
most tax are not the richest people in the country'
the second reason that statistic is misleading
is because that is talking about only income tax
so it's saying the people who pay the top one the
top 1% income taxpayers are paying 28% of
income tax um but actually income tax is only
one form of tax there are other forms of tax
which are tilted much more towards ordinary
people so for example the government raises
more from VAT and from National Insurance than
it raised on Income Tax. VAT (Value-Added Tax) is
a tax which is on consumption; ordinary and poorer
people paya much higher rate of VAT as a % of
their incomes and that is because ordinary people
spend a much higher percentage oftheir income
and National Insurance is a taxwhich
specifically excludes incomefrom wealth
which is the vast majorityof the income
that richer people make umso
basically these statistics are misleading
and the best way for you to understand it is for
me to explain exactly what is really happening
which is we have a tax system which is
'broadly progressive' meaning people who have higher
incomes pay higher tax at sort of ordinary income level
so if you are earning £100,000 a yearfrom your
work you'll pay a higher rate of incometaxand
tax overall than somebody earning £15,000 or
£20,000 a year that stays true up until about
£150,000-£200,000, then once youstart
seeing people who are earning above
£200,000 what we actually see is that the
rates of tax paid start to fall significantly
and the reason for this is that our current
tax system is very well designed for taxing
working people so if you work for your money
which most people do or I work for the money
that I made especially if you're earning a high
incomeyou will pay relatively high levels of tax
you know into the sort of 60%'s once we include
National Insurance and Income Tax and VAT
but the tax system as it is is not reallydesigned
to tax people whose wealth comesfrom...
whose income comes from wealth um if
you don't understand the concept of income
from wealth I would recommend you watch
the video on the channel what as well
um that basically explains that there's a huge
amount of wealth in this country not just housing
but also a lot of commercial wealth: land, shopping
centres, office buildings, factories, wind farms
industrial wealth and these are owned by richer
people and they generate enormous amounts of
income from this world so if we consider someone
like Rishi Sunak who is worth about according to
The Times Rich List £700 million, he will make
every year from his wealth probably something like
£30 million, remember that's not from his
work right that is the money that he just gets
for owning lots of stuff like your mortgage or
your house um the way the tax system is designed
it is very possible for people such as Rishi Sunak
who generate huge amounts of income from wealth
to legally avoid... well first of all theydon't have to pay
income tax on a lot of that and they can legally avoid
many forms oftaxes, so the end result is
in many cases thesepeople pay rates as low
as 10% or sometimeseven lower
on the income from their wealth
so what we actually have is a tax system which is
progressive for ordinary people so the rate you pay
is higher the more you earn and then once you
get into this realm of very very wealthy people
the rate starts to collapse and in particular
the rate on inherited wealth especially for
phenomenally wealthy people falls to zero
so you end up in a situation where the tax
system is not really progressive it's basically
progressive for ordinary people and essentially
optional for wealthy families um I think that's
probably the fairest way to describe the tax
system that we have which is essentially it's
a class-based tax system so I'm a relatively
wealthy person I'm worth you know more than a
couple of million pounds and I earnt that through
working so when I worked I had to pay it was
actually a 50% top rate of income tax at the time
at the same time as I earned a few million pounds
from working the Duke of Westminster inherited
£9,000,000,000 which is you know maybe three
thousand times what I earned and he paid nothing
so I think that really highlights essentially
what we have is a class-based tax system I
earned many many thousands of times
less than the Duke of Westminster
but I come from a poor family so I have to
pay 50% tax the Duke of estimates that earn
a thousand times more than me but he is the
Duke of Westminster so he pays 0% tax
and I think it's it's quite interesting that
in a way the tax system is kind of moving
back towards what it was like in medieval
times where essentially working people pay tax
to the aristocracy um because if you look
at for example someone like Rishi sunak
the amount of tax that he pays is enormously
less than the amount of cash flows he receives
from working people and increasingly a big chunk
of the tax that you pay literally goes towards
paying government debt interest to the Rich, um
so you pay your tax - a lot of that goes to the Rich
then you pay your rent - that goes to the Rich
you pay your mortgage - that goes to Rich
you go to buy food and that goes to the landowners
youbuy energy and that goes to the energy owners
um so essentially what you have essentially looks
increasing like a very very extractive system
and the lack of taxation of the rich creates
a big problem with flows of wealth so recently
I've been really trying to lobby politicians, very
unsuccessfully, to start taxing wealth, tax working
people less on their income and tax wealth more
and you know I've been trying to push them to tax
people who have a wealth of over £10 million; 1%
of their wealth um and they don'twant to do that
but wealthy people will make three,four, five
percent income on their wealth anyway so
what that means is even if you were to tax
them one percent they would still generate an
enormous excess income that they could then use to
compete with your kids to buy property and I think
when you think about the tax system I think
another story that illustrates it quite well
is you know I've got friends um you know
I think of one friend who's you know very
well educated and he earns probably about three
times average income now and he lives with his
mum to try and save up money to buy a house and
because he's earning higher than average income
he probably pays you know above 50% ifyou
include National Insurance on his on his income
um and when he goes to buy properties those
properties end up getting bought by people who
got given half a million pound tax-free from
their mum, um I think this kind of highlights
what's happening you know my friend is paying
50% because he's from a poor family and that
person who buys that house is paying 0% ontheir
income because they're from a better off family
and The Duke of Westminster inherits £9 billion
and pays nothing because he's from a very very
rich family um so yeah the tax systemas it is, I
should probably just talk briefly aboutVAT & N.I.
National Insuranceis a form of income tax
that only applies toworking people
only applies to work, so you knowmy income,
I pay income tax on some of my income
but I don't have to pay any National Insurancebecause
I don't work (well I do work but I don't makeany money)
from this work um so we have a formof tax
National Insurance specifically targetedat
working people then you have VAT which is on
consumption now very rich people consume very
very small percentage of their income so they pay
very little VAT, so VAT targeted at ordinary people
National Insurance targeted at working people
Income Tax avoidable for the rich, Inheritance Tax
avoidable for the rich, the end result is you have
a tax system which looks progressive for ordinary
people because you're only comparing yourself to
people around you who are ordinary people at the
same time you have this small group of people
who are phenomenally Rich who are increasingly
buying everything you don't often get to see
in day-to-day life that they are paying nothing
generating huge amounts of income and using
that income to buy the rest of the assets soum
who pays tax uh if you're a working person in
an ordinary financial situation uh, YOU!
who doesn't pay tax? very wealthy families, the
people whoreceive your mortgage payments
your rent payments, um the money you spend
on food andbills, they don't pay any tax on that
and they are then using that money to buy the
rest of the wealth so it creates this really bad
structural problem where because we're not taxing
the rich, because they have these huge incomes
they are then buying all of the rest of the
assets so they kind of end up being like a
black hole for assets sucking all of theassets
out of society and if we don't take anyaction
against that it is inevitable that in youknow
20 years, 30 years, ordinary families will
not have any assets left basically. it willbe very
difficult to own property and if you doown property
you'll be forced to have an enormousmortgage
um so yeah tax is paid by working people
it's not paid by the rich, if we don't do something
about that inequality will grow massively we will
lose our middle class who will lose their assets
um I'd really encourage you you know if you're
an older person who owns property to think about
what that means to your kids and your grandkids
um if you're a younger person this is probably
no news to you but um try and think about ways
to communicate clearly to older generations you
know what this means for the future of the country
if we don't fix the tax system then the
majority of the people in this country
would end up being very poor but if we do
fix the tax system we can change it so um
yeah understand what's happening share this video
and um yeah help us to change it thank you! happy?